and the Oscar goes to Lady Gaga Mark
rotten Anthony
thank you to Mark Ronson to Anthony
rosamunda to Andrew Wyatt my co-writers
I love them so much to my sister my soul
mate I love you my family's here I love
you Mom and Dad Bradley there is not a
single person on the planet that could
have sang this song with me but you
thank you for believing in us if you are
at home and you are watching this right
now all I have to say is that this is
hard work I've worked hard for a long
time it's not about winning but what
it's about is not giving up if you have
a dream fight for it there's a
discipline for passion and it's not
about how many times you get rejected or
but you fall down or you're beaten up
it's about how many times you stand up
and are brave and you keep on going
thank you